I am Daenerys Stormborn of House
Targaryen of the blood of old Valyria I
am the Dragons daughter and I swear to
you that those who would harm you will
die screaming
you
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
today I want to make a short video
discussing House of the Dragon the Game
of Thrones prequel show that HBO
currently has in production I have made
some update videos about this before but
as far as I know it's been roughly six
months since any juicy details have been
announced which is why I want to talk
about this today this is something I
recently discussed with some of you on
social media what I'm wondering is
should we be concerned since we haven't
received any additional information
about the new show now I did notice a
lot of you were asking if the new show
was already cancelled so allow me to go
over everything I know thus far because
it has been a while since we talked
about any other news shows that are in
the works now before Game of Thrones
even ended we were told HBO was working
on creating five new shows that were set
in the isang of Ice and Fire universe
obviously with the success of Game of
Thrones in combination with the amazing
story Georgia our Martin has created HBO
wanted to continue making shows in this
realm now out of those five shows we
were only told what two of them were
about the first one that was given the
greenlight by HBO was a show that was
set during the long night george RR
martin was actually calling the show the
long night but he later retracted that
statement right around the same time
there were reports that the show would
be called blood moon now regardless of
the title we knew it would be set during
the long night when House Stark was
founded and the White Walkers were
created I know I was very excited when I
found out they were making a show during
that time because I always believed that
the Starks and the White Walkers were
related in some way so I was hoping the
new show would reveal that it really did
seem like this show would be the first
one created after Game of Thrones ended
they hired several different writers who
did finish a script for the first season
they hired some well-known actors to
play a few of the different characters
and they even filmed the first episode
but this is where things started to fall
apart
shortly after this is when it was
announced that the long night successor
show was cancelled that first episode
must have been really awful because even
Dan and Dave got a second chance when
the executives HBO did not like the
first episode they hand it in for Game
of Thrones now I know that many of you
think it might have been canceled
because of how Game of Thrones ended
which might have something to do with it
but honest
who knows what really happened behind
closed doors all I know is the long
night successful show is no longer in
production thankfully when this was
announced we did get some great news by
the next day right after they revealed
the long night was canceled and they
also revealed their and moving things
along with another show mostly based on
George RR Martin's book fire and blood
which did make a lot of sense at the
time because it was just released as
well not only did they announce they're
working on the new show they also
announced the new show was getting a
full series order so it sounds like we
would get a first season no matter what
unless something catastrophic happened
of course House of the Dragon is said to
take place three hundred years before
the events of Game of Thrones it goes
back to a time when House Targaryen the
only family of Dragonlords to survive
the doom of Valyria took up residence on
Dragonstone and like I said since george
RR martin recently released fire and
blood the writer should have some good
source material to use not to mention
george is also currently working on
another volume of fire and blood so
there will be even more material to draw
from i know i'm very interested in
getting to see how the show turns out
but let me get back to my original
question in the video since we haven't
heard any news in over six months should
we be worried about the status of the
new house of the dragons show one of the
last updates revealed the first episode
would be released sometime in 2022 which
means they are most likely still in the
early phases are writing the script now
we're obviously still under lockdown due
to the virus so i'm sure that has slowed
down production quite a bit i am hoping
the writers and producers are taken this
time to focus on writing an interesting
and exciting story for their first
season i hope they're doing everything
they can to avoid making the same
mistakes Dan and Dave made in Game of
Thrones
especially those later seasons I would
like to think HBO wants to avoid that
kind of negative attention and criticism
so maybe this also has something to do
with why we haven't heard anything in
several months maybe they want to make
sure everything is right before they
announce anything else but this is all
speculation maybe everything is still
right on schedule
they could even give us some good
updates sometime soon or we could find
out this show will have the same fate as
the one set during the long night
anyways I said I wanted to keep the
videos short I just wanted to talk about
something that has been on my mind
recently I would love to hear what all
of you have to say about this
you think how so the dragon is still in
its way or do you think we should be
concerned let me know down below as
always I want to thank everyone for
watching also I want to let everyone
know I will be doing a live stream on my
patreon tomorrow night I would like to
start live streaming for all my patreon
supporters at least once a week so keep
your eyes open for that I will be making
an update over there shortly if I don't
see you there
have a great day I hope to see you here
again for the next video bye
[Music]
[Music]
you